aprendamos un poco de resortes digamos
que tengo ahora un resorte todo el mundo
más o menos ubica los resortes son como
como este tipo de materiales hechos como
en espiral que tienen esa habilidad de
retomar su forma original después de
formarlo y digamos que tenemos este
resorte aquí digamos sobre el suelo y
que está justo pegado a la pared ok
entonces este resorte está pegado a la
pared muy bien entonces digamos que este
es su estado natural aunque haya y no le
estamos aplicando ninguna fuerza
entonces este punto final vamos a medir
donde se encuentra este punto final
sobre lo digamos vamos a ver qué le va
pasando a medida que nosotros le vamos
aplicando fuerzas pero este es el estado
natural digamos el estado de reposo sin
ninguna fuerza interactuando sobre el
ahora pintemos este mismo este mismo
resorte
vamos aquí volvemos a tener este este
muro donde está atado y el suelo
muy bien debería hacerlo más derechito
muy bien ahí está y vamos a marcar donde
estaría el punto digamos de reposo ahora
pensemos que estamos aplicándole a este
resorte una fuerza de 5 newtons muy bien
entonces nuevamente al aplicarle una
fuerza de 5 newtons lo que va a ocurrir
con este punto es que se comprime un
poco verdad si antes estaba aquí al
aplicarle una fuerza digamos de de 5
newtons y va va en esta va en esta
dirección hacia la izquierda verdad
entonces son son menos 5 newtons digamos
que tuvimos un desplazamiento de 10
metros muy bien entonces si tenemos un
desplazamiento de 10 metros estamos
pensando que este resorte se comprimió
debido a que yo efectuó el perdón yo yo
le imprimía una fuerza a este resorte
muy bien entonces la pregunta es la
siguiente cuánto se desplazará a este
punto hacia la izquierda
si yo aplico ahora no no
5 newton verdad si ahora la aplico 10
newtons la pregunta es bueno será será
la relación digamos lineal o sera
cuadrática o no se no se puede haber
muchísimos casos ok y de hecho tú ya
puedes más o menos intuir a lo mejor que
ocurre pero lo que sí es un hecho es que
se va a comprimir verdad eso eso sí lo
sabemos va a estar más comprimido así
que hagamos el experimento
digamos que apachurra mos con un poco
más de fuerza este resorte muy bien
entonces lo que sabemos es que se va a
comprimir ahora que tanto se comprime
bueno eso ya es distinto entonces y aquí
estaba el reposo
digamos aquí digamos aquí estaba cuando
aplicamos 5 newtons
ahora este va a estar acá y quizás de
hecho lo pinte de más
ok entonces digamos este esté más o
menos de los 10 metros estaban más como
por acá y resulta que esta relación es
lineal y que es que digo cuando cuando
las relaciones lineales estoy pensando
que la digamos la distancia a la cual se
o que tanto se comprime el resorte es
proporcional a la fuerza que le
aplicamos entonces aquí le estamos
aplicando una fuerza de menos 10 newtons
y digo menos 10 minutos porque estamos
aplicándolo hacia la izquierda verdad
entonces lo que sí sabemos y qué bueno
se tiene una ecuación para describir
esto es que la fuerza de restitución la
fuerza de restitución de nuestro resorte
es proporcional en dirección contraria
al desplazamiento de nuestro nuestro
resorte muy bien entonces si nosotros en
este caso por ejemplo en este en éste
segundo ejemplo tuvimos un
desplazamiento desplazamiento d
10 metros porque se desplazó hacia la
izquierda y siempre ha sido esa nuestra
convención verdad que si nos desplazamos
hacia la izquierda entonces tendremos un
signo negativo entonces tenemos de aquí
que la fuerza
aquí tenemos que la fuerza es menos acá
por menos 10 metros verdad por menos
días vamos a dejarlo así muy bien
entonces lo que tenemos esto simplemente
son 10 acá y nuestra fuerza de cuánto
fue la fuerza fue de 5 newtons verdad
día ahora ojo esta fuerza la fuerza de
restitución ahorita vamos a ver pero
tendremos que es de 5 newtons y esto
debe ser igual a 10 acá entonces la acá
es igual a digamos si pasamos dividiendo
el 10 tendremos un medio verdad
un medio y ahora la fuerza es positiva
por la siguiente piensa en esto nosotros
aquí estamos aplicando una fuerza de 5
newtons supongamos que el resorte ya no
se está acelerando muy bien y por por
ello como ya no se acelera quiere decir
que hay una fuerza igual de grande que
la de 5 newtons pero en dirección
opuesta verdad por eso es que ponemos
este menos porque en la fuerza de
restitución que es aquella fuerza que
tenemos cuando este resorte ya no
acelera esta fuerza de restitución va en
dirección contraria al movimiento verdad
por eso es que lleva a nuestro nuestro
signo menos muy bien entonces eso es lo
que pasa con los resortes y de hecho
podemos utilizar ya esta información
para saber más cosas cuando aplicamos
otra fuerza distinta por ejemplo si ya
no aplicamos 35 newtons y no vamos a
aplicar ahora 10 newtons ya sabemos
cuánto vale la cca entonces tendremos
que la fuerza es igual a menos
un medio x muy bien entonces si ahora
tenemos que nuestra fuerza fue de 10
newtons entonces bueno 10 minutos hacia
la izquierda la fuerza de restitución va
a ser de 10 minutos pero hacia la
derecha verdad y esto es menos un medio
x xi ahora pasamos multiplicando al
menos un medio tendremos menos 20 es
igual a equis quiere decir que si
nosotros duplicamos la fuerza vamos a
duplicar también el digamos el
desplazamiento que tiene este resorte
muy bien y eso es algo muy interesante y
eso es justo una de las propiedades de
que esta relación sea lineal es decir
que sean proporcionales muy bien vamos a
hacer un último ejemplo
hagamos un último ejemplo no sé digamos
que tenemos tenemos este mismo resorte
por supuesto a algo que olvidaba casi
decirles es que esta relación que
tenemos hasta acá arriba tiene un nombre
y de hecho tiene el nombre justo porque
es una relación muy importante y esto es
la ley de hook ok y se le conoce como
ley de hook en honor al físico británico
a un físico británico del siglo 17 muy
bien entonces
digamos ahora que tenemos este este
resorte
y vamos a poner un poco más derecho
muro tenemos nuestro resorte de la misma
forma
porque ella ahorita lo pintamos ahí
tenemos
el resorte muy bien
algo así
muy bien pero ahora vamos a aplicar una
fuerza de 2 newtons ok pero hacia la
derecha quiere decir que estamos
estirando nuestro nuestro resorte y
digamos que logramos moverlo un metro
muy bien podemos estirarlo un metro esto
quiere decir que va a haber una fuerza
de reacción verdad la fuerza de
restitución hacia la izquierda verdad y
que también tiene que ser de dos newtons
entonces vamos a notar todos nuestros
datos tenemos dos newtons y se desplazó
un metro
se desplazó un metro entonces nosotros
podemos ahora calcular quién es nuestra
constante acá por qué
si nosotros aplicamos
si nosotros aplicamos una fuerza de 2
newtons veamos
entonces si tenemos una fuerza de 2
minutos pero en este caso la fuerza de
restitución va a ser hacia la izquierda
quiere decir que va a ser negativo y
tendremos menos 2 será igual a menos k
por el desplazamiento que en este caso
es un metro verdad y es positivo porque
es un desplazamiento hacia la derecha
quiere decir entonces que nuestra acá
vale exactamente 2 y la fuerza de
restitución es menos 2x muy bien y
entonces si tenemos un desplazamiento
hacia la derecha por ejemplo si tenemos
un desplazamiento de 2 metros quiere
decir que la fuerza de restitución va a
ir hacia la izquierda y será de menos 4
newtons entonces espero te hayas
divertido aprendiendo un poco de
resortes y en los próximos vídeos
haremos un poquito más de ejemplos de
este estilo